[Music]
from the studio dumb enough to sell
their marble franchise rights to Disney
comes yet another movie that only exists
to set up the Avengers Captain America
the First Avenger stand tall for a
superhero movie with an important
message it's what's on the inside that
counts except for when it comes to
fighting or being respected he's making
me cry or getting laid
women aren't exactly lining up to dance
with the guy they might leave Johnny
Storm the Human Torch wait no that's
wrong movie meet Steve Rogers a grown
man's head CGI'd onto a little boy's
body he's a skinny kid from Brooklyn who
dresses like it's the 1940s so basically
a modern-day kid from Brooklyn
watch as he becomes a superhero in the
most American way possible steroids
[Music]
he'll juice up to become Captain America
a soldier with the powers of being a
little bit stronger than a regular
strong guy Ultimate Frisbee and super
sobriety I can't get drunk forget Tony
Stark's ridiculous 3d holograms and
return to an analogue world full of
lever bullying
[Music]
switch flipping
button press e
dial turning
[Music]
and people calling out percentages with
absolutely no context along with Captain
America as he faces off against the evil
Red Skull who along with everyone else
in sci-fi and fantasy is played by Hugo
Weaving cheer as the captain defeats as
legendary arch-nemesis in a brisk
2-minute bond ties all to leave more
time for foreshadowing the Avengers
introducing the plot device from the
Avengers unnecessarily freezing himself
so he can be in the Avengers and an
after credits scene that is literally a
trailer for The Avengers starring the 90
year old virgin Tommy Lee grows one face
to face red face you face German Capote
dr. Strangelove the winter spoiler agent
love interest and Robert Downey senior
Captain America the first Avengers
trailer Raiders of the Lost Ark get it
better just saying hey screen junkies
can't get enough of my buttery voice
then check out honest game trailers over
on Smosh games how's that for a slice of
fried gold alright alright alright
the web is dark
full of spoilers remember Sully when I
promised to kill you last I lied
The Legend of the red is way hardcore